álex up quizás sea una de las figuras
más polémicas del entorno de nicolás
maduro este empresario colombiano lleva
desde junio de 2019 acusado por eeuu por
supuesto lavado de dinero washington
asegura que lavó activos por hasta 350
millones de dólares de tramas ilegales y
que es una pieza fundamental para los
negocios del gobierno venezolano sin
embargo mientras estuvo en venezuela no
pudo ser detenido su situación cambió el
12 de junio de 2020 ese día tomó un
vuelo en caracas para llegar a irán a
realizar negocios pero mientras su avión
repostaba en cabo verde las autoridades
del país lo detuvieron por una orden
internacional desde ese momento
venezuela intentó hacer lo imposible
para que regresara al país a pesar de
las presiones de eeuu desde caracas
defendieron su papel de diplomático y su
inmunidad algo rechazado por el tribunal
constitucional de cabo verde su defensa
encabezada por el ex juez español
baltasar garzón intentó apelar a
organismos regionales africanos e
incluso se trató de incluir a saab en
las negociaciones con la oposición en
mexico pero no hubo éxito
e informar a la opinión pública
la decisión de incorporar al diplomático
venezolano
álex up como miembro pleno de esta
delegación de su detención arrojan
numerosas dudas sobre su futuro y lo que
puede implicar que decida hablar sobre
determinados asuntos comprometidos para
nicolás maduro si me permiten la pasión